steve and matt's on whom there is a lot
expected now in the absence of noah
syndergaard and marcus strom yeah he he
moves to the number two spot it's gonna
be um
fun to watch how he responds we know how
he pitched in the second half he pitched
much better he was great in spring
training and good in summer camp won 17
games for the braves last year 4.02
e.r.a from harvard westlake school in
los angeles
empty one out second inning the pitch to
duvall back door breaking ball is lifted
in the air to right field toward the
corner back toward the wall and gone
it just kept carrying and carrying and
slicing to a shorter part of the fence
it's a solo home run for duval and a
one-nothing atlanta lead
breaking ball there not a bad pitch
caught a little bit more of the plate
than than mats wanted to and
i'll put a good swing on that ball just
kept carrying the right field right off
the pooch well you know those dogs can
take a lick
nemo heading ninth in the order against
the left-hander after picking up two of
the mets six hits yesterday batting lead
off
the curveball line the other way coming
on quickly is riley to pick it off at
the shoot tops for the first out well
nice hitting by
mr nimmo hang with him
nice break on that ball by riley here's
jeff mcneal
a little dribbler off the mound comes
freed and the backhand oh
and he gets mcneal
instead of doing the uh the pivot he
decided to
go with the backhand and put it right on
target and he just jammed mcneal there
big time freed looked like he was
running the wishbone in oklahoma no one
runs the wishbone anymore right as i
said conforto walked his first time up
good photo lashes one to left center
field that's going to go in the gap and
go all the way to the wall mets have
their first hit of the day and conforto
pulls in at second base with a one-out
double
so after freed had gone four and a third
without allowing a knock
here's rosario with a runner at second
and one out and he hits one toward the
right center field gap and that's gonna
split him and that's gonna bring in the
tying run conforta will score rosario
turns second he's going to try for three
albies will not make a relay throw it to
run scoring triple for ahmed rosario and
the mets have tied the game at
one-on-one
forto and rosario with opposite field
gap extra base hits so now the infield
drops back to double play depth mcneil
has flied out and hit a comebacker oh
for two mcneal clubs one out to left
field back goes riley that'll get the
run in rosario tags he'll come in and
score nemo will hold it first sacrifice
fly for jeff mcneal gives the mets the
lead it's 2-1 new york outstanding
hitting by mcneil
so after freed didn't allow a hit
through the first four and a third the
mets put up a couple of extra base hits
and chased them both home
josh tomlin will take over for max freed
again for max five innings two hits two
runs five strikeouts
and now the veteran
35 year old right hander josh tomlin who
was such a big part of the braves
bullpen last year
and he just got sespidous to swing and
miss a
hat trick for joanna's cespedes third
strikeout of him today two outs
familia like diaz yesterday diaz had
that uh strong inning for the save diaz
trying to familiar sorry trying to pick
up from last year
and freeman rolls one into the shift
mcneal playing in shallow right field
throws him out one big out for familia
to start the seventh that was the split
finger gary
for the rollover for now
matt's went six a lot of run on two hits
a walk seven strikeouts a home run 93
pitches job well done by steven who
leaves with a 2-1 lead making his mets
debut
the 32-year-old former yankee dylan
detansus 3-2 and swanson goes down
swinging on the breaking ball but
chances went to the breaker on three and
one and on three and two to get the
strikeout what the three batter minimum
giveth that sometimes taketh away at
least that's what the braves are opening
here in the eighth and now acuna who's
gone over three today struck out against
wilson in the eighth inning yesterday
struck him out
wilson pulled the string and he got a
cunha to retire the sides and now
suspenders
and cesmidis pokes one into center field
and that'll fall for a base hit just
reach down and flick the slider
into center now the mets have their
fifth end of the day eduardo nunez will
run for a suspicious at first base diaz
handily retires albies and freeman and
the braves are down to their final out
of the afternoon the pitch
is hit near toward right pretty deep
conforto to the wall we're tied it's a
home run
the braves down to their last strike get
a lightning bolt from marcelo zuna stir
it up marcel we're tied at two apiece
and thankfully he tried to trick him and
with the new rule in extra innings the
player who made the last out of the last
inning the ninth inning will become the
runner that is placed at second base to
open the image
grounded up the middle and gets through
for a base hit
duvall had to make sure the ball got
through to center field mariznick's
throw comes home but it's cut off and
the run scores and dansby drives one
back through the middle and the braves
take the lead three to two not going
this time and that ball is just out of
reach of rosario dansby leap frogs over
the shortstop marisnick overruns the
ball no further advance
little dribbler strickland bobbles
thought about holm has one play it's to
first and ender drives home dansby
swanson the braves have scored a couple
of runs in the 10th inning
in the air toward right center field
mariznick on his horse still going won't
get it it's down it's up against the
wall
camargo will score
and contreras with a double
that is his first big league hit so now
nunez is first at bat as a met
that's down by three nunes at the plate
and he flies one out to center inciate
coming in and mcneal will stay put at
third base i'm sure no sense taking a
chance that's the first stop got to be
careful with ramos he represents the
winning run
smoke towards short dansby's got it the
flip to second is in time and the braves
in extra innings have taken care of the
meds